it's quite clear from the first of these
that we've put out that people love the
lego model or East a lot of people do
find it useful so yeah we want to take
it on a bit further today we have this
pre-prepared
linked list of barbecue items which are
all in alphabetical order and last time
we covered about how would you insert a
new item into this list if it was
something that you'd forgotten to buy
and you bought it later this thing
called P is pointing at exactly the same
structure at the head of the list as
starties so we now have got the problem
of inserting burgers alphabetically into
this thing list now doing that with
conventional techniques well we covered
that before and it it's ok it works but
it's somewhat messy I wasn't happy never
have been happy over the years with the
way that that's done in the conventional
single level pointer technique is there
anything you can do that's better
well yes there is this came about or was
made clear to me many years ago now in
that I as many of you know originally
did this in a language in the early 70s
called alkyl 68 and the people who had
done the Algol 68 compiler for the
machine we were working on was the royal
raid our establishment in movem in the
UK and one or other people there who did
that compiler could be Subhan kuba
Phillip would would just said to me and
my colleague Annie Walker at the time
they said you're teaching this stuff now
you do realize that Algol 68 can do the
triple ref technique which previously
has only been available to assembler
programmers we said really can it yes
and yes he can
so what on earth is this well despite
that technical name is actually a
pointers to pointers technique it's very
powerful and you might think well if
you've got pointers why on earth would
you want pointers to pointers
well the strange thing about this and
the really remarkable thing
is that in the end it makes your
procedure for doing things simpler not
more complicated so what do we do well
we've got burgers here and we're going
to try and put it into the correct place
just as before but instead of using a
previous single level pointer and then
having to say well it's all very well
they can probe what the strings are but
what you had is the problem was you've
forgotten away you came from and when
you splice burgers into this list you
need to know what's ahead of you but you
need to know where you came from it's
the previous blue box and if you're not
careful you lose any way of getting on
that so if you look at my solution using
traditional techniques I carefully keep
a second pointer to remember where it
came from this will no longer be
necessary here we go we introduce a
thing which I'm going to call tracer
tracers contents are of type pointer to
pointer to things so the way you declare
that in --see is it's a thing star star
because she declare things by their
contents in C so inside tracer is a
thing star star it's a pointer to a
pointer to a thing so therefore it's
absolutely right that you can make and
look at this piece of chain here that's
to say that a pointer to a pointer
although it's a pointer is not the same
thing as a single-level pointer to a
thing it's perfectly okay for me to
attach that to there and saying that the
contents of tracer is a pointer to a
pointer to a thing so I'm pointing to
the address of a box which inside it has
got a pointer to the thing which in this
case is the head of the list you
basically use a technique known as
casting of pointers you can take a jump
you can dereference you can follow the
link you can either do it once to get to
here or when you've got to there you can
jump the pointer again and get on to an
actual thing at the head of the list so
it's two steps removed yeah so starting
here you jump there you then you look
along the black hose
and you say I'm looking at something
called yeah
and I want to put in my thing here which
is burger and the idea of this is always
that you insert ahead alphabetically of
where you are if that's what fits no
burger isn't earlier than beer in the
alphabet it's later than beer so what
you have to do now is to try and look
ahead at the next thing which we will
discover is chips now here's the really
cool thing about using the tracer
pointer to pointer technique is that if
inspecting beers had no we've not gone
far enough yet what we now do instead of
awkwardly moving our single level
pointer down the list is take this
blessed a great link and do wait for it
folks this is absolutely cool ok if I
made tracer originally point at a blue
box because type wise it was right then
it follows that all of these blue boxes
in turn I can make it point through
those to take a peek at the next one
down in the list it's as simple as that
you see type theory by colors a green
thing can point at the blue thing but it
can't point directly at a red thing so
you look at this and you think well by
the principle of colored Lego type
theory if I can make the green thing
point it's any blue thing I can do that
and then you say but what does that
imply in the program
it's implies in the program that you've
got to be able to find the address of a
blue box that's embedded within a
particular thing structure and no look
what you could then do is you start with
tracer you jump to that box but then you
jump down the firemen's hose and you can
take a look and you see that the next
thing is chips you see Wow
I've just seen beer I'm looking ahead by
this sneaky technique and I see chips
that's where I belong I want the burger
thing in there so this is completely
magic but does it generalize and does it
work and the answer is yes it does
because
by stepping one step backwards and going
through an intermediate blue box before
you do anything
the crucial advantage it gives you is
that having decided that burgers does
belong in here the problem we previously
had of saying where the heck did I come
from
is solved because tracer is still
pointing at it so you say to tracer let
me dereference you once and I've then
got the address of the box I want to
alter so that it points at the burger
thing and we end up just like we did I
think last time but using the tracer
technique of saying there goes Berger we
know we're in the right place and if you
remember we constructed let's get this
right do the long one first that one
goes here and then finally you when you
complete this splicing in operation by
taking that pointer the previously came
off the beer thing turning it round and
putting it on the blue box there so job
done but the big point is that you were
able to keep half a finger on where you
came from that's the thing at the same
time as using that to look ahead and say
yes alphabetically I'm correct I'm after
beer and before chips it's like standing
at a road sign and knowing that you're
standing in London yeah but the road
sign says Bristol yes why you're
standing at the point of you go there
it's pointing that we are see both those
things actually so that's right
so let's just take a quick look and
honestly there's very daring of me I've
actually put out the routine that does
this in C and will provide this for you
if you don't believe that this works
just compile the program I give you and
run it and say wow it does work